i never knew that i would fall in love
with chimpanzees i never knew that i
never in my life are you in love with
kimberly could you say that like right
like right now yeah i love you talking
about i love about all my bone my heart
my wait you're in you're in love with
her or do you love her like right now
yeah
i flew halfway across the world to meet
the man of my dreams i messaged him and
he messaged me back and i was like oh my
god
[Music]
ooze man you're back on 90 day fiance
before the 90 days but this time with
the new woman kim
yay
i'm back on the show i'm i'm happy and
excited about that
and um i'm back together with queen
chambali yeah okay i have so many
questions i'm not even gonna lie so i'm
ready for that okay well let's go let's
get into it the last time you watched
the show it was with elisa who is also
an older white american woman do you
have a time is this your type i can't
say that i actually don't have time i
just
my type is somebody who is going to give
me peace somebody either young or old
as long as
you are somebody who is going to give me
peace you are somebody who's going to
like understand my business and support
me not just giving me trouble then
you're my type okay well that's that's
really what i want to touch on because
you mentioned you want somebody that
will help you keep your peace
it doesn't seem like kim is going to do
that and we know that lisa did not do
that so my question for you is what made
you come back and go down this road once
again after all the drama you
experienced with lisa
um so
actually i'm
i'm a believer i'm a muslim and then
in the islam we believe that anything
that happened to you in this life
is already it's already been written so
what happened between me and my ex
or something that was written you know
and i can avoid it so i just let it go
and i want to move on why i am down here
with this lady queen kimberly is because
compared to the relationship i had
before the experience i had before she's
she's loyal so yeah she's nice actually
she's good to me well whose idea was it
for you to do the show again is that
something that you kind of pushed for or
was it kim going to the show doing 90
day fiance appearing yeah it was me it
was me actually it was me because um tlc
said that due to what happened
if actually
i'm in any new relationship and i'm
ready to tell them
they can record it and i was like okay
then
and um i was the one that you know come
up with the show even my last
relationship with lisa i was the person
that come up with the show i was the
person that applied for the show with
lisa
so i was going to come up with the show
actually but she really wanted to do the
show
and then i was checking and looking and
see who i can really show it and i was
observing and i feel like i think i can
go with her
interesting okay we're gonna get more
into that in a minute but i want to know
more about your connection with queen
kimberly she slid into your dms i'm sure
you have a lot of fans that
hop into your dms but what
millions okay what made you respond
i was talking to kim bali but as my
friend
my fan because kimberly came to you as
my fan
and then from there
i keep on you know like paying attention
because i never know that i for the love
of team
i never knew that i never in my life
so did you for are you in love with
kimberly could you say that like right
like right now yeah i love like checking
out i love about all my bone my heart my
wait you're you're in you're in love
with her or do you love her like right
now yeah
i so much i am alone
i love chicken bali i can say it
anywhere in the world
i love i am not shy i'm not ashamed
i am proud to say that i love her and i
hit my chest i love her for real what do
you say to fans who are saying cut the
bs oozeman i mean
you're using these older women for tv
time or to get a green card what do you
say to those people
i'm not gonna lie
okay fine fine i'm gonna answer to you
sometimes
people that were saying that may not
understand me
but i want to i want them to hear this
if
the government of the united states say
that some certain people from another
country
can have green cards
in social condition maybe they have
importance in the country of america and
they were giving green card or no maybe
because they got married to this
american person whether woman or man and
then they are entitled to green card
then
i think i can fall in that you're
basically saying if you really wanted a
green card you can go about it another
way instead of talking yeah yeah if i
really want green card it's easy i am
not skim bali because of green card and
i'm not with kimberly because of tv why
go on tv in general just to help with
your career or just what i applied to be
on tv
because i love being on tv this is what
i've been doing since from childhood
okay and
the tlc
opening a platform said that
if you are in this category you can
apply
why other people are not being
questioned that may have been i'll be
questioned all the time okay most people
are most people are being questioned but
i think why you're specifically being
questioned is because you have a career
in entertainment you're a rapper so
this platform could potentially assist
you in other ways other than you just
falling in love so that's why it's a
question
okay
um if that is your question i will tell
you i think the question she goes like
why are you being with you know not
american ladies instead of being with
nigeria ladies i think that should be
fair that should be a nice question to
ask i mean that should be reasonable not
really nice but like
and that into your point
that is a question because the big
question here is is your goal to get to
america i am actually not doing anything
to get to america but if be doing that
is a reason for me to be to america so
be it you know like i think it's a good
thing in the history of africa
especially in nigeria we have bad name
and reputation in the name of scamming
that we scam like nigerian scam people i
send my ex money after we recorded in
2019 she got back she was having a toy
problem i sent her 2 000 from here my
own sweat and had any money i send it to
her she can deny well scamming in my
opinion i don't just view it as just
money i view it as
someone using someone for an opportunity
how much would you say 90 day fiance has
helped with your rapping career
you know i'm not going to lie 90 day
visa has helped me a lot
i think um
tlc shop entertainment
are the biggest thing in my life so
i would never deny that
whatever i know a lot of people be like
um that's why you were there i don't
care i have two more questions one what
inspired your name your rapper name
soulja boy because you know we have
soulja boy over here in america
actually when i had the name sojo i
don't even know about it
oh
yeah because in africa wrapping doesn't
last we we go on afrobeat we love music
that you can dance into the club with
and rapping does not like dice rap like
you know like driving is existing but
like it's not making it that big so
the reason why i get the name soldier
boy was because i have two brothers same
one same that they're into the army i
have one brother who is a police he is a
policeman we are all the same one
december and i was like if i am going to
be an artist let me use soldier ball and
the soulja boy means soldier s.o.j
that's how we call a soldier
that's how it come up and then american
rapper he's great he's big i know
but
what i'm trying to say is that his name
is not
soldier for soldier his name is soul
like s-o-u-l
is soul for the heart okay last question
before i let you go if you could some
story line sum up your storyline this
season with one word
what would it be
romantic amazing interesting and
beautiful
that sounds really positive and i don't
know based off the trailer if that's
what i um i am a positive person all the
time unless if you don't know me i love
that i love that you know that's a great
thing but i think you you miss drama
maybe when you give me drama i'll give
you back you know let me tell you one
funny thing before you go the reason why
who see me the way they see me because
they know about michael michael of
angela he tolerated enough you know why
because he let the world know that he
actually want to be to be in america is
his goal
me
to be america is a goal but that's not
the only goal me
my goal is to be the number one artist
or among the number of top top artists
in the world that's my problem and
that's why people think that you're
using kimberly
um if that's what they think then it's
fine
you think that later you're gonna know
who i might watch the show and you'll
get your answer
you